[Music]
my name is Miranda Dawson I'm a graduate
student at MIT in the lab of Alan
jacksonoff and I Engineer new ways to
image the brain my research career
actually started organically when I was
in elementary school and I would carry
around this like neon yellow notebook
and I always use glitter pen and I was
always like taking down observations or
coming up with different theories for
how the world worked I chose
bioengineering as my field of study
because it seemed the most on the
intersection of our humanity and also
all the aspects of engineering that I
enjoyed my work is trying to translate
the tiny molecular event
and then find an interesting way to
amplify it so that you can see it with
something like MRI really what we're
interested in doing is taking these
molecular tools for molecular Imaging
that we've been building and trying to
apply it to a model of addiction to
understand at different points in the
cycle what's happening to the brain for
as much as we know about the brain there
are still far more that we don't know
and so any progress in dissecting the
complex you know relationship that you
know our brain environment is having is
extremely helpful for thinking about
future Therapeutics and treatment and
also just you know understanding what
makes us tick
foreign